welcome to this video playing I am ego
who is that Igor no David struts okay um
so at the bird opening let's see it's
going for him reversed verse Leningrad
set up yeah I'm getting this Queen B 6
idea in so he prevented the check with
e3 and now with d3 okay so how does
black play that I really don't know my
where a teammate of mine recommended
that night h6 set up to me I don't know
I'm not even sure it was with c6 or not
to be honest it looks a bit weird at the
moment here because any night f5 is
going to be answered with a form and I
totally hmm i don't really see if I've
as being very good
now maybe I can do it and it looks a bit
strange ok it's not taking which I
thought was far more critical but okay
um why it's not a bad move before but I
expected the other one yeah so what am i
doing now it's not not great yeah that
thing ok position is somewhat on
ammonia's maybe I should try to keep it
close and get the night over to f7
that is definitely not how the black
side of this should be played looks
totally wrong hmm now I don't know never
studied one f4 really is going for
g-form understandably KO here at least i
get in this move to get rid of my bishop
i'm glad that i can get that in but yeah
anyway he's got a pretty pretty good
setup here very active okay if i go i
can do that right g5 I can take
hmm okay maybe I manage bishop c1 and g5
simply closing down the whole thing I
came that's interesting this Bishop f4 a
mafia take stakes maybe if he takes it
I'm getting the e5 square and my nights
are just correctly correctly placed in
regards to the e5 square an interesting
I would move probably but see
threatening something I don't see I
don't see it at the moment I mean taking
one air for wasn't a good move probably
and what else was there the night was
attacked if I go g5 he's got night h5
that's not good okay interesting so
oh okay i don't think that g5 is any
good i can take though and here i can
take g six actually hmm guys got night
h5 this is a this is an annoying move
annoying moved to face
and and something that I'm overlooked
taking with the king is probably a weird
a DM but okay if a chick here just
checking me and I'm going back but what
exactly is this move g4s hanging as well
right this one okay
yes that's no good what can you do him
yeah the worst thing is he mean he can
take on f6 which is probably good but he
can also just pile up and I haven't no
moose okay it takes here I want us
wondering if I can maybe to take on g4
it looks really wacky but at the moment
I don't see why it's not working
ok show me show me why this is not
working
you
i rue gave one probably I move like that
is strong now look everyone is strong
just just an improving move and at
that's overlooked everyone yeah yeah
yeah that was there was a point I mean
it was lost probably anyway but that was
of course a good morning okay but yeah
it should be lost but let's see let's
see how
95 chick okay but I'm here now if you
most of the night I have this check
their class got this wrong unfortunately
the queen bee 7s sir is a very easy
winning probably
I even look I have to just wins if your
check if you don't see anything better
even that wins check
alright 95 chick
what's the problem here check check
check what check check check check check
check check mate yet that is the most
undeserved victory ever probably wow I
was really one I wanted to resign but
somehow I know he kept so long for the
simple move so I continued what and it's
a shame II completely outplayed me Jim
what can you do to you know ah around
him I wrote here I thought it should be
maybe reasonable within Bishop having
managed to get outside of the chain but
this is a problem okay I mean I can go
g5 and maybe I should just completely
closed the whole thing down and it's
much better I really underestimated this
is night h5 north garage I around here
I'm basically losing now the engine is
just minus 0.8 but if you give it more
time this will probably climb yeah and I
suspected there you gave to is even
stronger piling up I have no moves
really but okay this is good enough as
it is ah I can do this haha this is
actually okay that's very interesting
this is actually actually quite
interesting yeah I'm a porn down but the
Jeep on can be attacked that's not a
clear clear position at all engines has
0.4 honey wow that means look F to a
stronger because of that line yet I am
lost I'm just lost look everyone I think
even and shipmate so it would be sad
surprising if he had a 95 is made check
that's also made yeah I probably made it
with multiple check check
yeah I'm threatening nothing he can do
whatever he wants I mean like this for
example I have no move Quincy 70 we went
here and while i take it check every
just a mouse lip he wanted to go queen g
two check check check check check check
it was so shocked I didn't want to draw
now entertain to make one yeah I was a
terrible game but can't you can you say
ah ok well thanks for watching